the FBI raided the home of the head of
the payroll company that abruptly shut
down leaving more than 250,000 people
without paychecks these photos from the
Daily Mail show agents searching the New
York home of Michael Mann as part of an
ongoing fraud investigation into my
payroll HR Meg Oliver reports on how the
company is accused of stealing millions
of dollars from customers video and
photos obtained by Daily Mail calm
showed the FBI descending on Michael
Mann's lakeside house in Edinburgh New
York this week a law enforcement
official tells CBS News the agents were
armed with a warrant to collect
potential evidence they are
investigating his company my payroll HR
an online service that handles payroll
for small companies it mysteriously
closed earlier this month and is accused
of leaving around two hundred and fifty
thousand employees without paychecks and
holding around thirty five million
dollars in wages the employees shouldn't
have borne the brunt of this catastrophe
Melanie O'Malley owns a small bakery in
Albany New York she was shocked a few
weeks ago when her payroll came to a
halt and she noticed she was missing
money we don't know if we're gonna get
that money back
and there's more questions than answers
still a week and a half in O'Malley is
out about a thousand dollars but says
there are people who have it worse most
of us live paycheck to paycheck people
like Brooke Taney a manager of for
employees at B Reds Bistro in upstate
New York at the end of last month she
says they all had their most recent
paycheck withdrawn from their bank
accounts her employer had around 20
thousand dollars stolen each day there's
just more questions as to what happened
to the money where did it go Taney wants
to see Michael Mann held accountable
justice for us and I know for everybody
that's been affected by this would be
for him to go to jail the stress that
was caused to me and my staff and to the
four thousand plus other people we I
mean we can't get that back tani says
she and most of her co-workers have been
burst by their banks but they still
don't know if my payroll HR was properly
paying their taxes as from Michael Mann
he has not been charged with a crime and
it's unclear where he is and he has not
returned our phone I'm mystified still
mixed by how they were this company was
able to pull money out of the cash oh
yeah so at first we thought it was just
that these people didn't get their
direct deposit and then we learned as we
heard from Brooke that they were taking
it out so they're stealing the money
back as well thirty five million dollars
missing Michael man where are you people
have questions I think he's gonna be
returning you know I think he might be
in Portugal right now or somewhere
hiding out but we'll see he hasn't been
charged with a crime Megan thank you
very much